en este vídeo quiero mostrarles algo
bastante interesante acerca de los
multiplicadores de lagrange que hemos
estado estudiando así que la primera
parte solamente voy a poner en marcha
todo lo que hemos visto hasta ahorita
voy a hacer un resumen de todo lo que
vimos pero a la recta final creo que te
va a gustar bastante hacia dónde vamos
entonces uno de los ejemplos que te
mostramos y sigo pensando que este es un
ejercicio prototipo muy bueno de los
ejercicios de optimización con
restricción es que tú estás dirigiendo
una cierta compañía y esta compañía
tiene una especie de función de ingreso
que vamos a llamar la función r y esta
función r tenía dos variables recuerdas
las variables que tenían eran h para las
horas que trabajaban cada uno de tus
empleados y por otra parte teníamos am
para la cantidad de acero que íbamos a
comprar las toneladas de cantidad de
acero claro si estuvieras fabricando
algo metálico y bueno esta función r se
modela como una función multi variable
de a
pero esta vez no nos interesan mucho los
detalles así que no me va a importar
quién es esta función h pero lo que sí
me va a importar es lo que queríamos
hacer con esta función h lo que
queríamos era maximizar esta función h y
es que esto es algo que todo el mundo
quiere tiene todo el sentido queremos
maximizar esta función de ingresos pero
teníamos una cierta restricción este es
el mundo real no solamente puedes gastar
un dinero infinito así que en esta
ocasión dijimos que teníamos un cierto
presupuesto que habíamos llamado bm con
mayúscula y era un presupuesto de las
mismas variables de h y de am y bueno
tampoco me va a importar quién es esta
función ven así que me voy a poner aquí
tres puntos suspensivos pero lo que sí
me va a importar y recuerdan es que era
igual a una cierta constante era igual a
una cierta cantidad es decir la cantidad
de dinero que estamos dispuestos a
gastar así que en este caso eran
diez mil pesos y nuestro objetivo va a
ser maximizar una función como está
sujeta a alguna restricción como esta y
si pensamos en nuestro modelo mental tal
vez estés viendo el espacio donde
tenemos dos ejes un eje para x y un eje
para james o bueno espera más bien sería
un eje para h y un eje para am porque en
este caso nuestras variables son h jam y
los puntos en este plano les dicen las
posibles decisiones que pueden hacer
para una cierta cantidad de horas de
mano de obra y una cierta cantidad de
toneladas de acero y si piensan en el
presupuesto como algún tipo de curva
entonces en este plano todo el conjunto
de las haches y de las as que sean igual
a diez mil pesos me van a dar un tipo de
curva ya nosotros lo que nos va a
interesar es cuando se maximizan este
presupuesto recuerdas cuando se
establecen igual a una constante y no se
voy a decir que el máximo de esta
función es m estrella la cual va a ser
el presupuesto máximo posible y esto
dar una curva que apenas toque a esta
curva del presupuesto es decir que sea
tangente a la curva de la restricción y
si esto no te parece conocido
definitivamente deberías echarle un
vistazo a los vídeos anteriores porque
esto nos da una propiedad realmente
buena que nos va a ayudar a continuar
con el análisis la cual es la siguiente
que el gradiente de este vector r el
vector gradiente de esta función de
ingresos este vector gradiente va a ser
proporcional al vector gradiente de
nuestra función de restricción es decir
estas dos apuntan en la misma dirección
el vector gradiente de nuestra función
restricción y esto es porque los
gradientes son perpendiculares a las
curvas de nivel entonces la idea central
era que tomábamos al gradiente de esta
función de ingresos y hacíamos esto
igual
y no haga diente de la función be pero
lo hacíamos igual al gradiente de la
función ve multiplicado por una cierta
constante de proporcionalidad que ya
habíamos llamado lambda el famoso
multiplicador de lagrange y hasta este
punto
este valor de lambda no había sido tan
interesante solo es una constante de
proporcionalidad cierto ya que podríamos
garantizar que estos dos no eran iguales
pero lo que sabíamos es que apuntaban a
la misma dirección
así que acabamos de tener esta constante
colocada aquí y todo lo que realmente
dijimos es que bueno esta constante no
era igual a cero pero aquí es donde
lambda realmente importa así que si
recuerdas en el vídeo anterior introdujo
una nueva función llamada el la granja
no 10 de la granja no era una función
que dependía de estas dos variables
dependía de h dependía también de
y además dependían de mi constante de
proporcionalidad es decir dependía
también de lambda es una función de tres
variables es decir tiene tres entradas
las mismas entradas que tenemos en esta
función que queremos maximizar y en esta
función de presupuesto y además tienen
como tercera entrada a esta constante de
proporcionalidad así que observa es una
función de dimensión mayor que r y que
ve ya que tenemos hasta lambda adicional
y la manera en la que está definida era
la siguiente tal vez en un principio era
un poco extraño parece una mezcolanza
aleatoria de funciones que estamos
poniendo juntas pero la última vez
examiné porque esto tiene sentido y ya
parece que tiene un poco más de lógica
la forma en la que definía este la
granja no es tomar la función que
estamos tratando de maximizar la función
r
que bueno ya sabemos que es una función
que depende de h y que depende de a
ya esto le quitábamos lambda veces así
que déjame ponerlo lambda veces la
función del presupuesto la función be
que bueno también ya sabemos que es una
función que depende de h y de am ya esto
a su vez le quitábamos bueno a lo que
era igual presupuesto que en este caso
es igual a 10.000 así que déjame ponerle
un nombre a esta cantidad que es una
cantidad fija le voy a poner el nombre
debe entonces a esto menos b y bueno es
muy importante que enfatice en que está
bien es simplemente una constante en
cualquier momento se puede cambiar este
valor y no por eso está cambiando esta
función
entonces déjenme notar lo ven es
simplemente una constante y digo esto
porque recuerdan esta función la granja
en am está pensada para tres variables h
am y lambda todas ellas como variables y
por eso es una función multi variable
la razón por la cual definimos en el
vídeo anterior esta función es porque
nos da una buena manera compacta para
resolver el ejercicio de optimización
con restricción porque si nosotros nos
tomamos el gradiente de este la granja
no y lo iguala vamos a cero
esto nos daba una cierta solución y ojo
estamos igualados al vector cero este de
aquí sería el vector cero ya encontrar
una solución de esto que voy a llamar no
sean h estrella déjenme ponerle h
estrella coma a estrella coma lambda
estrella porque recuerda que la granja
no está definido para estas tres
variables es decir acabamos de encontrar
una solución que hace que esta función
gradiente de la granja no sea igual al
vector cero y bueno por supuesto podrían
encontrar varias soluciones a este
ejercicio pero lo que hace cada una de
estas soluciones es que si tú tomas esta
h estrella a estrella y estas dos
variables las introduces
de esta función que querías maximizar y
vas introduciendo cada una de ellas en
esta función r cuando encuentres la h
estrella a estrellas que te dé el valor
más grande en ese valor no va a ser ni
más ni menos que m estrella es decir el
ingreso máximo posible sujeto claro a
este presupuesto de 10 mil pesos a este
presupuesto que está igualado a esta
constante ven ahora lo que va a ser
bastante interesante cuando resuelves
está gradiente y se obtiene un valor
específico para lambda es decir para
esta lambda estrella que como dije no
solamente va a resultar la variable boba
va a llevar información de cuánto
podemos aumentar el ingreso si
aumentamos el presupuesto así que
permite mostrarles a qué me refiero si
tomamos esta m estrella me la voy a
poner aquí nos tomamos a esta m estrella
como ya vimos esta es exactamente lo
mismo que la función r
déjame ponerlo con su respectivo color
que la función era evaluada en esta h
estrella como esta estrella pero ahora
también vamos a poder ver a esta misma m
estrella pero como una función de esta
vez déjame escribirlo para que te quede
más claro m estrella ahora la voy a ver
como una función que depende de b y
bueno lo único que estoy diciendo es que
a esta función r
ahora la voy a ver así esta función r
la voy a ver como una función de h
estrella y ahora imagínate que podemos
cambiar esta vez es decir piensan cómo
cambiarían su ingreso
si nosotros aumentamos el presupuesto no
sean a 20.000 o si lo aumentamos a
15.000 pesos algo que sé yo así que
seguramente te vas a hacer la pregunta
qué pasa cuando cambias esta vez bueno
pues el valor maximizado
se estrella es estrella va a depender de
ven así que h estrella va a depender de
bem y va a pasar lo mismo para la
estrella a estrella también va a
depender ahora de esta vez cuando
cambien el valor de esta constante van a
cambiar los valores que hacen que el
gradiente de estela granjea no sea igual
a cero y entonces ahora la pregunta va a
ser a medida de que cambio esta vez como
va a cambiar h estrella y estrella bueno
esto depende de varias cosas
ustedes saben va a depender de la
definición de r y todo lo demás pero en
principio
en este contexto pienso que es muy poco
intuitivo tienen un ingreso máximo
posible y eso depende de su presupuesto
ahora lo que termina siendo algo
realmente hermoso es que si nos fijamos
de nuevo en esta lambda estrella lambda
estrella y hasta parece un poco mágico
va a ser igual a la derivada de esta m
estrella de m estrella con respecto a
esta b es decir la derivada del ingreso
máximo posible con respecto a esta vez
al presupuesto y permítanme mostrarles
lo que realmente esto significa
imagínate qué este valor está lambda
estrella lago igual a 2.3 bueno en un
principio parece un número bastante bobo
inclusive tal vez todos lo van a ignorar
entonces lo dejan aquí a un lado y
solamente se fijan en h estrella a
estrella y la meten aquí en nuestra
función r pero si tú ves que el hambre
estrella es igual a 2.3 lo que realmente
significa es que para un pequeño cambio
en el presupuesto digamos que este
presupuesto pasa de ser 10 mil a 10 mil
un pesos
10.000
pesos entonces estamos aumentando el
presupuesto sólo un poco un pequeño bebé
y la relación de cambio en el ingreso
máximo que vamos a obtener dado este
pequeño dpm va a ser de 2.3 es decir lo
que significa es que estamos aumentando
este presupuesto máximo m estrella va a
aumentar 2 pesos con 30 centavos esto
por cada peso que aumentes en tu
presupuesto y estoy seguro que esta
información realmente la quiere saber
cierto si ves esta lambda estrella y es
un número mayor que 1 entonces van a
decir oye tal vez deberíamos de aumentar
nuestro presupuesto si lo aumentamos de
10 mil pesos a 10 mil un pesos solamente
un peso observa estamos haciendo más
dinero así que tal vez mientras lambda
sea mayor que 1 deberían seguir haciendo
todo lo que sea necesario para aumentar
este presupuesto y yo creo que es un
hecho bastante sorprendente porque
observa
que surge de la nada así que lo que voy
a hacer en el siguiente vídeo es probar
para ustedes que esto es verdad es decir
porque este valor de lambda estrella es
igual al cambio en el valor máximo entre
el cambio del presupuesto la partida de
lo que estamos tratando de maximizar con
respecto a la constante vez por ahora
sólo quiero que traten de relajarse y
asimilar lo que significa todo esto que
acabamos de ver y sobre todo en el
contexto de este ejercicio económico
específico incluso si nunca vieron la
prueba o nunca entendieron la
demostración creo que esta es una
pequeña prueba de sabiduría porque esta
información es bastante interesante e
incluso bastante útil para tenerlo en
cuenta
acerca de este multiplicador de lagrange
así que con esta idea los dejo y los veo
en el siguiente vídeo